[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we all know that
the American flag has endured in its
many forms as the ultimate symbol of
freedom justice and the American Way but
did you know that our nation's flag was
designed by a high school student from
Ohio according to legend the original
American flag from 1776 was sown by a
lady named Betsy Ross it had 13 stars in
a circle representing America's original
13 States as more states joined the
Union people kept adding more stars to
the flag
so by 1958 the US flag had a total of 48
stars for the 48 states of that time
which brings us to our high school
student Robert heft Roberts history
teacher gave his students and open-ended
assignment make a project illustrating
your interest in American history it
could be anything so Robert who was
jazzed about hearing that Alaska and
Hawaii were going to become States cut
up an old 48 state flag in his
grandparents basement and designed his
own vision for a 50 state flag when he
turned in his final assignment Roberts
teacher said anyone can make a flag and
it's got the wrong number of stars the
grade came back Abby - Robert tried to
explain his idea to his teacher who
replied I'll change your gray when your
flag is accepted by the US Congress game
on Robert wrote 21 letters and called
the White House 18 times until one day
in 1960 Roberts phone rang
[Music]
hello it was President Eisenhower with
news that Roberts 50 state flag design
had actually been chosen as the new
official flag of the United States the
president invited Roberts Washington
where he saw his American flag fly for
the first time on July 4th 1960
[Applause]
since then Roberts 50 state flag has
remained unmatched is the quintessential
symbol of America but I know what you're
thinking whatever happened to that B -
Roberts teacher honored his promise and
changed the grade to an a salmon sushi
isn't Japanese it's Norwegian okay
here's the story until about 1995 raw
salmon was not consumed in Japan and
this was for one big reason Pacific
salmon has parasites oh so no salmon
sushi sashimi no spicy salmon nothing
what but obviously that all changed
thanks in part to this guy Norway had a
problem they had a lot of salmon and too
small a market looking east they set
their sights on Japan a country that
loves raw fish so much it's willing to
pay five times the price yes for sushi
grade so nor we formed a committee and
hired bjorn from 1986 to 1991 I worked
for okay their job was to convince
Japanese consumers that Atlantic salmon
was safe to consume raw and this was
hard just take for example pork if some
guy from Norway came here and said here
er pork meat raw it's safe it's really
yummy we'd be like man you're crazy
it was basically American perception so
we had to change the whole country
Buuren and his team got to work they
made the first ever salmon rolls and
serve them to businessmen in Japan we
they didn't like for a long time it took
actually ten years okay I get the proper
breakthrough in the market so there it
is salmon sushi didn't exist before 1995
Bjorn
on behalf of the world we thank you
[Music]
without Abraham Lincoln and really his
beard Milton Bradley the godfather of
board games would have never existed
bold statement I know but let me explain
[Music]
the game of life the spinner the cars
the choices college or career kids are
no kids
lawyer or farmer this family game night
staple was once a pretty morbid game
back in the 1800s Milton Bradley was in
the lithograph business following the
Republican National Convention of 1860
Bradley printed thousands of images of
Abraham Lincoln who was clean-shaven at
the time shortly thereafter Lincoln
debuted his iconic beard rendering all
of Bradley's prints worthless
his lift the graft business went
belly-up so Bradley was forced to try
something new he came up with a board
game a seemingly dark and twisted board
game appropriately named the checkered
game of life the game functioned in a
similar way to how it does now
there was a spinner colored circles that
moved around the board and of course
squares that could either make you or
break you the squares on the original
game were overwhelmingly grim boasting
actions like disgrace poverty ruin crime
prison and well suicide regardless the
game flew off the shelves kids loved it
and Milton Bradley went on to own family
game night fast forward to about a
hundred years later they revamped the
game trading Bradley's morbid squares
for the more delightful ones like pay
day or graduation which we have all come
to know and love and so there you have
it the story of the game called life
thanks Lincoln Tootsie Roll seems simple
enough that piece of gooey chocolate
wrapped up in a perfect little bite but
believe it or not these tasty treats
save the lives of US Marines in the
Korean War
[Music]
in 1950 at the North Korean Chosun
reservoir US Marine troops were engaged
in battle the Marines are running out of
ammunition and called for an airdrop of
16 millimeter mortar rounds codename for
these bullets tootsie roll
when the supply is fell from the sky
troops were surprised to find boxes
filled with the actual candies bullets
this fluke turned out to be a blessing
in disguise freezing cold temperatures
had cracked vehicle fuel lines leaving
troops stranded and although the candies
were frozen they softened easily in the
mouths of servicemen so good Marines
quickly realized they can melt the
candies down to a putty and seal the
broken pipes good as new when the
chocolate refroze they were able to
drive to safety in their newly
functional vehicles the Marines to
successfully escape the reservoir admit
that tootsie rolls had a big hand in
their survival and they call themselves
the chosen few I'd call that a pretty
sweet victory wake up before this and
this and this and this that sound people
in Britain and Island woke up like this
that's right being an alarm clock used
to be a job and they were called NACA
uppers we're traveling back in time for
this one so let's get historian in here
just sit here huh yeah fantastic
oh sorry I'm late the knock her up and
didn't call them good one Richard my
name is Richard Jones and I'm an author
on the history of London okay let's see
if we got this right from the early
1800s to the 1960s waking people up was
a paid job yes and this was done with a
bamboo pole oh yes yes most certainly
this is the age where people started
working
they've got to be up early for their
shift and of course most people are on
minimum wages haven't got a long odds in
their house consequently there's no one
to wake them up so that's where the
knocker up or the knocker up that came
in see in big industrial cities like
London Birmingham and Manchester knocker
APIs used poles to reach the windows and
these poles had a hook or knob at the
end which made them pretty effective
you could cinch that down went a bit
like nails being on blackboard
wakey-wakey
other knocker uppers mostly women used
pea shooters to aim at the windows or
not but why not just shout wake up wake
up well you do have to keep the
neighbors in mind so the big question is
who knocks up the knocker upper the
evidence suggests that the not proper
just didn't go to bed sometimes with no
proper might serve like tune himself to
be able to wake up at 3 a.m.
ah mystery solved play us out Richard we
had to knock her up and Anaka up had to
knock her up and Anaka ups knock her up
didn't knock on knock her up so I'll
knock her up didn't knock us up because
he's not up when you think of Japanese
cuisine a few foods come to mind
sushi did you know that salmon sushi is
actually Norwegian yeah we did a story
on that one maybe you think of mochi we
did that one too and tempura but guess
what tempura is actually a Portuguese
dish oh boy here we go
the Japanese tempura you know is done
two ways either with seafood or with
vegetables right and the batter is light
made with cold water wheat flour and egg
pretty standard this tempura can be
found dating back to the end of the 16th
century in Japan but as we know Japan is
much older than that so why did it
suddenly show up
the answer is Portugal around 15 43 a
Chinese ship with three Portuguese
sailors got off course and landed in
Japan on Tanegashima Island fast forward
a bit and the Portuguese because of this
happy accident are now trading goods and
arms with the Japanese then in 1639 the
Portuguese were kicked out of the
country a few things however remained
including a dish of battered and fried
beans called machines they ortho useful
versions sub-rule cook here pushing your
sword that's Manuela brandão chef at
Papa service one of the best spots in
Lisbon to get a cheese dosa machine is
the water cycle sustained a severe
disease but Maria's Informer equally
300sl Gavin we're both Agra da ville' no
secular society who because racine are
OSHA for me as vision now of course over
the past 400 years Japan has put its own
spin on the dish but you know it's a fun
fact next time somebody in your group
orders tempura
[Music]
[Music]